[Música]
oi meu nome é lena mansur e hoje vou
falar pra vocês
a discriminação da mulher esse tema tem
relevância às nossas em nossas vidas
porque desde muito tempo atrás nós
mulheres temos essa discriminação
joana d'arc já daqui sempre foi uma
mulher muito religiosa e uma vez quando
foi pra igreja eu ouvi uma voz falando
pra aí pra guerra lutar e essa voz seria
o seu amuleto e ela pensou ver a
santinha votar guerra lutou e venceu e
tornou seu melhor soldado do batalhão
mas vestida como homem e quando
descobriram que ela era mulher
falaram que ela era uma bruxa lutar
melhor que os homens e faz efeito uma
porção para lutar melhor e todos aqueles
que agora e que haviam recebido com
festas agora recebiam com gritando luxa
luxa de meninas as mulheres nós podemos
tudo
joana d'arc como contei para vocês é um
exemplo de superação e da calú que quase
morreu duas vezes e é um exemplo de
superação para nós mulheres
chiquinha gonzaga que encheu de músicos
ouvido de mulher de homens intelectuais
malala que quase morreu pelo direito de
estudar
michelle obama que é defensora das
mulheres princesa isabel que tirou os
brasileiros à escravidão
taís araújo a defensora das mulheres
negras e quem não se lembra de hermione
ela é a representante das mulheres no
mundo inteiro
uma mulher que mudou o mundo salvou
vidas
era uma vez uma menina que queria ser
agente secreta
chamava-se nancy wake aos 16 anos viajou
sozinha austrália e convenceu o jornal
contratava eclodir da segunda guerra
mundial um mundial é o se uniu a
resistência francesa lima ac contra os
nazistas era tão difícil encontrá-la que
foi apelidade rata branca tornando-se a
número um na lista de procurados pelos
alemães
certo dia 16 20 frase pelo amor de deus
os aliados não fizeram pular de
paraquedas na frança para ter que fritar
ovos com bacon
homens tempo para pensar se eu te
fizeram a seguinte pergunta qual o nome
do primeiro cientista que vier em sua
cabeça quando você diria a você você e
você
vocês perceberam que um falou mulher e
todos os outros falaram homens vocês
disseram 12 pessoas eram esses
e quando vocês puderem poderiam ter dito
diz mary cury rosalind franklin anos
gertrude é lyon vai tocar só a grande
maioria falou homens e vocês sabiam que
o primeiro algoritmo de computador
prefeito por uma mulher e que o formato
do cromossomo foi feito para por uma
mulher a lei reflita lugar de mulher não
exigindo carro dirigindo um fogão uma
mulher nunca jogar futebol com um homem
lugar de menina brincando de boneca e
não praticando esportes uma mulher nunca
vai gerenciar uma empresa com homem é
são frases que nós mulheres ainda
ouvimos em nosso dia-a-dia movimentos
contrários à discriminação da mulher
ocorrido o movimento da mulher
iona discriminação da mulher minha tia
participa da corrida do movimento da
mulher ea onu faz várias campanhas para
que essa discriminação acabe a história
da minha vó minha voz da escondida e
quando se formou começou a trabalhar com
direito
atualmente ela tem seu próprio
escritório de advocacia
até hoje muitas profissionais deixam de
ser contratadas por serem do sexo
feminino e principalmente mulheres
negras
você já sofreu uma discriminação por ser
mulher
uma vez um dia minha mãe foi
entrevistada e perguntaram a ela se ela
já havia sofrido algum tipo de
discriminação
ela não se recordava e comentou o fato
com um defensor público que disse quando
os céus entram na sala eles olham
primeiro pra mim e depois para a senhora
e qual o problema nisso
os céus pensam que o juiz é o homem e
quem é que está na sala e jamais a
mulher que nunca seria uma juíza
minha tia gabriela manssur promotora de
justiça e corregedora é defensora dos
direitos da mulher e participa da
corrida movimento da mulher movida pela
seguinte frase mulher de verdade não
aceita a violência
essa é minha
se quisermos conseguidos para instante
pense nessa questão
você está ajudando a acabar com o
problema hoje existem vários artistas
que fazem homenagem às mulheres por
exemplo a band o tio fez uma homenagem
falando que nós mulheres podemos tudo
você também pode ensinar aos outros que
isso é muito errado e eu digo não à
discriminação e antes de terminar a
apresentação gostaria de dizer duas
coisas a primeira é sobre uma reportagem
que olhe que eu fiquei sabendo por uma
doutora que eu fui
ela falou que ache que as chinesas são
as melhores matemáticas do mundo então
deram duas provas para ela uma das 2
matemática uma sempre lembrando que ela
era chinesas e outra sempre lembrando
que elas eram mulheres mas que elas
fizeram lembrando que elas eram chineses
eu achei uma nota muito boa e nós que
elas fizeram que lembrando que elas eram
mulheres
ela chegará uma nota pior e isso é uma
discriminação que elas trazem consigo
mesmas por pensarem que a mulher tem que
lavar roupa tem cuidado se você tem que
fazer um monte de coisas penso ah eu sou
chinesa tem que ser boa
na matemática seus eu sou mulher eu
tenho que cuidar da casa e eu queria
dizer uma frase que tirei do meu livro e
só de treinar para garotas rebeldes sem
fala sobre mulheres extraordinárias para
garotas rebelde de todo mundo são em
grande distante de com bravura e na
dúvida lembre-se você está certa
obrigada pela atenção
[Aplausos]